[Music]
Kyler's in Georgia how's it going man
it's going good dude thanks from you
yeah my pleasure so I really like your
submission and let's just start off
you've got an interesting background
here but you just spent a couple years
in the military yes I have I was in the
US Air Force for six years it was a
great time and I just recently got out
yeah so you were in from 19 to 25 you
are 25 years old right now
and we've been at just first research Oh
26 all right happy birthday um why did
you go into the Air Force what made you
decision you know make you make the
decision to go into the military
so if you don't mind I'll give a little
back story of my life just real quick
synopsis until I'm born in South
Carolina in Charleston South Carolina
my mother was a crack addict I was put
into adoption the people I were adopted
to they later on adopted me later in my
life and as I got older I realized that
there wasn't really a chance for me to
go to college for what I was trying to
do the other money gave to their blood
daughter and I had no chance of getting
into college
so my best chance was to go into the
military get a GI bill and didn't make
it from there yeah so you mentioned you
were adopted later do you mind me asking
how old you were when you were adopted I
was adopted when I was about I'd say
about 11 12 years old and before that
were you sort of bouncing around foster
families or what do you remember about
that part of life so the earliest I
remember I was about five years old now
I lived on a farm when I was in foster
care and then I moved back in with my
mother and then later on at about seven
years old I got put back into the foster
care system and then from then on I was
in the foster care system bounced around
from two houses then moved in with my
adoptive parents and I lived with them
until I was 18 years old yeah working
from what you can remember I mean I know
it's a young age but what was your fear
what was it like to be a young child
that age and
bouncing around from from house to house
I know you only know one life but what
did that feel like um when I was
thinking about it in a moment I really
don't have any feelings of what what I
was thinking at the time I was just a
kid I didn't really think anything of it
I just thought I was moving from house
to house I thought that's how every kid
lived their life at the time as I grew
older I was part of four brothers we got
split into two my oldest my youngest
they went somewhere else and me in the
middle brother we live together and he
kind of taught me the ropes of what was
going on with life yeah so then you do
the six year the five years or so in six
years in in the US Air Force and now one
of the things that you want to talk
about was race and politics because your
personal politics aren't exactly what
somebody might think if they were just
to judge you by looking at you which
obviously I don't do but tell me a
little bit about your your political
ethos right now yeah so um if I had to
click myself on a spectrum I'm a little
bit to the right of Attila the Hun so a
lot of people don't realize that why
look at you think that I'm I'm probably
in a liberal because I'm black or but
what a lot of people don't get is a lot
of black people are more conservative
than they put on they just have some
liberal leanings because of the Democrat
Party as he came through the 80s and 90s
they put on more of this show up you
know we're here for civil rights and
which I did um but growing up black
you're basically branded with the D sign
as soon as you're born and when I got
into the military a lot of that changed
me because when I was about between
those ages of 19 and 25 those are the
time for your the most moldable and I
wasn't going to college so I wasn't
being influenced by the I guess I'll say
the propaganda that was going on in the
college at the time so my my outlook on
life was a bit different from a lot of
people of my race and of my age so but I
don't I'm somebody who's who thinks
about pulling myself up by the
bootstraps I something I really believe
in and and I've made my way through it
without having to depend
on the government basically yeah that's
really fascinating I guess I never
thought of it like that that in a way
you escaped that indoctrination of the
college years because you went into the
Air Force that that's kind of great in a
way so you you see this now
so what's right to you what what is
being right mean to you
so being right to me um a lot of just
come from the gamergate years I know
you've had a couple people on that talk
about gamergate and that was a real
trigger for me I had your some things
that kind of were like hey you know I'm
not really with Democrat Party on that
but it was gamergate for me when they
started to come at the video game I'm an
avid gamer this is how I probably
suppress some of my depression as I was
younger with what I had to go on and I
see my mother or father throughout my
younger lives I mean video games was my
escape and when I started to see the
media start to try to put their
tentacles into and they try to put their
uh I'm not even say liberal I'm going to
say as you put it regressive propaganda
into the medium that's when I started to
really push back against that yeah did
you ever think that you are going to
have a political reaction related to
video games because to me that's what
made gamergate so bananas it can escape
for so many people a wonderful escape as
you said to to not have to deal with
certain things or not a fill you know be
depressed about a certain thing and then
next thing you know that I like
tentacles also because that's what it
was they just jumped in on this thing
and and something something kind of
terrible happened although now I I would
argue that some goodness has come out of
it yes um
it is this kind of kind of sad and to an
extent because a lot of people who I
would have probably been on the same
side with you know I don't like to see
injustice racism and things like that
but as some people is somebody who I
actively follow now ben shapiro flooding
show me where the racism at is that and
i will find it with you if you cannot
just say it's a systemic thing we have
to show me where that will tack them
together get rid of it then after that
then we you know we may have our
differences
see you from there yeah so you basically
have from what I senses you you hate
identity politics you you want to be
judged as yourself and and you see no
use in it amongst you know friends and
and co-workers things like that do you
get judged for that because that's one
of the themes that I get from a lot of
my audience is that they're afraid to
carry a little out of the mainstream
that they're afraid to say it
I do matter of fact I have a roommate
she's she's a more of a pro-black more
along with black lives matter than I am
I personally do not like black lives
matter because the propaganda that they
put out a lot of this goes deep into the
weeds of prog rock out matter with going
into looking with their website saying
and things of that nature which I won't
get into but they do not focus on trying
to actually help off the black community
what they want to do is separate us from
the police it were I think that in these
areas such as Chicago and New York and
all these places that need more policing
they ask for less and that's the wrong
that's the wrong way to go for that I'm
not saying that we need a police state
however we do need more police in these
areas to try to help out the downtrodden
because the number one killer of black
men is black men which is a problem so
when you when you get into arguments
with friends and things and you know
I've had a bunch of people Larry elder
who who change my views on a lot of this
really and who ladies out your fat yeah
so and if you watch my first interview
with him I said talking about his
systemic racism a he basically just
clubbed me over the head and and it did
change me it really did because because
facts has been says you know neither
went over yeah exactly so when you've
got into debates about this do you find
you of a trick or or any gimmick to get
people to agree like if you say well
wait a minute Atlanta and Ferguson and
Chicago they're all Democratic mayor's
does that help is there is there
something because that's what people are
always asking me for what are the tricks
to get people to listen really when
you're at lists when you're talking to
somebody who has the mind for change
it's possible for them to say okay I'll
grant you that and we can kind of move
for lack of turn move the goalposts a
little bit from there but when people
they are stuck in their mindset they
will try to they will find a way to
circle back around to make everything
about white supremacy in little such um
so if you say that you know somebody
who's a millionaire replaced basketball
or football you know they've made it out
whatever gonna say well that's just
because white supremacy is allowing them
to get out just like you can't get
anywhere with that right right right
if white supremacy existed or at least
in the numbers they like I definitely
would have been in the NBA cuz I got a
pretty decent jump shot so the other
thing the other thing that I wanted to
hit on before we wrap up is you talked
about the mean generation as one of the
things you wanted to talk about and I
think it fits perfectly within where
you're talking about so you're a gamer
and you're a politics guy what does that
mean to you the mean generation so the
mean generation to me is the generation
of that's growing up the Millennials who
don't think that you should take
everything so serious now there are some
aspects where you should take things
seriously however when you're online
you're on Twitter and when somebody says
you a mean a bit that means I've been
called everything from [ __ ] to ankle
Tom to grease monkey to jungle bunny
every whatever you name it I've been
called it what it does affect to me I
don't allow it to get to me I laugh at
all obvious it means I said means to
other people that's what I'm trying to
get to is that you should be so
soft-hearted about these things now when
it gets them to family you don't I don't
really like to touch into other people's
family but if it's just mono a model
that's why I like to stick yeah and I've
been trying to push this idea this meme
out there because I when I go to schools
I'll ask the crowd sometimes I'll be
like do you guys think the alt-right is
really a bunch of white supremacy or do
you think they're just you know [ __ ]
posters and Pepe and catch a cat you
know kekaa Stan and they're trying to
upset everybody because it's fun and
almost everyone says that and it's like
if the mainstream doesn't get on board
that
the disconnect is going to get wider yes
it's very true lies I'm really getting
on to the mean generation following
people like a star one of akkad but you
Catalan yeah and plenty of others I've
been on pole a half an h and all these
places where people put their means and
it's all just shitposting it's not
people who want to try to ruin people's
life or destroy people because they have
a different skin color anything is if
you allow them to get under your skin
they will continue big it's not because
they want to hurt you because you're
just weak willed knows how I look at
yeah well I totally hear you and it's
been a pleasure talking to you and what
do you think you want to do are you are
you trying to figure that out right now
because you're pretty recently out of
the Air Force yeah I'm going to college
right now I plan to try to go in to be a
lawyer
and I didn't know a lot of people say
that I should probably avoid this but I
want to go into politics I want to try
to help people out because I see it but
I don't want to be dragged into that
that um how I look at it like the black
caucus where they have this wall a large
amount of wealth but then are really
helping out the constituents like they
say they are I don't want to be part of
that all right well here's the here's
the deal if you go into politics I
promise you I will if you make an actual
kandacy and you're running designing
your first interview will be right here
also I appreciated they alright I'm
talking to ena in Sweden enos how are
you I'm gonna light tar you day I'm
doing well I'm looking forward to
talking to you you have you have really
a great story that gets to so much of
the heart of what people are talking
about these days you are a Syrian
immigrant into Sweden so tell me a
little bit about growing up when did he
move to Sweden and that whole thing I
came to Sweden when I was about three
months old so I've been lived her my
whole life
yeah but the thing is I grew up in a
predominantly immigrant area so I've
grown up with a culture of immigrants
and so at home I would learn one set of
values and in school I would learn
another
yes so that's one of the things that a
lot of people talk about that the the
immigrants aren't integrating in a
certain way so what so tell me a little
bit about just your home life and that
first and then we'll talk about the
bigger society stuff and well yeah I'm
lucky actually I've my parents came to
Sweden and they both started working and
they studies and started working and
they both have a full-time job and
education has always been very important
in my household but still there was this
conservative the these conservative
values we had from our homeland and not
really equal rights for women in the
household and such things and really my
friends around me has the things that
the values at their home some worse than
others yeah so so I know that so one of
the things that people talk about when
they're talking about this is the
difference maybe between culture and
religions so when you talk about like
those conservative things related to
women or maybe gay people or whatever
else was that kind of religious based
for you or was it just culturally based
meaning just from the culture of Syria
not necessarily having to do with with
Islam no it was actually from religion
but those things that when people say
it's culture they forget that religion
plays a huge role in the culture of the
in the Middle East it's really the same
thing there yeah so as a as an immigrant
and a darker-skinned person growing up
in Sweden where there's a lot of very
light-skinned people what was that like
for you actually I I always say that
that's maybe not the experience of
everyone here in Sweden but I've never
met right-wing racist in Sweden I've met
a literally that will treat me like
unless because you know I'm darker
skinned and I need help
and such things but
I've never met someone that will be
bigoted against me because of my soccer
skill it's really open and yeah yeah
that's fascinating because we hear that
you know these these right-wing groups
are appearing and you know using racism
and all the stuff but when you talk it
seen that but tell me a little bit more
about the left-wing racism I think
that's what we've been referring to as
the the soft bigotry of low expectations
that these people mean well but thus
they start treating you differently
exactly and it's really the subtle
things they will not put you as as to
have high standards of other people and
like they will always you'll see it for
example in school stay in Sweden in
predominantly immigrant area you'll see
kids as young as eight years old wearing
the hijab and their left-wing won't
prettified it because you know the
Xterra culture but if their children
were forced to wear the hijab they would
be against it totally yeah so are you is
you're only 18 so you're young and
you're obviously incredibly bright and
outspoken and all that stuff do you feel
that you can express these contrary
views within your community and within
bigger society and I think it's
important to say that in the Middle East
it would be much harder I I have free
speech in Sweden it's really that it's
self-censorship air people won't speak
up and will accuse you of racism and six
of them if you speak up against against
those things I get I will speak up for
example in school where most of the
people there will be left-wing and I
would express like ideas that doesn't
align with everyone else and I will be
able to say it and there won't be any
problems but the people will have the
idea that you're still racist or and
sometimes I won't always
with the feminist values of my school
and they all think it's because I'm from
an immigrant background and you know
people from their will to be feminist
yeah I mean it really it's like it's
like the height of absurdity in a lot of
ways because you are a woman you are
educated you are an immigrant all of
these things and it's like they're
treating you there ironically treating
you as a lesson so when you explain this
to your friends are you able to to get
these points across I mean are you
winning any battles in your own little
in your own little experience actually I
go in a school where there are very bad
people and I love my school and there is
some radical feminists there and
sustenance but I when I share like
videos on Facebook and we'll have like
discussions over the over lunch
there it will exchange ideas sometimes
and sometimes it will get heated
sometimes we will actually get to a
middle ground and we'll see where we're
coming from yeah but but I think that in
general in the Swedish society that is
not happening yeah what do you do for
fun what's what's an 18 year old doing
for fun in Sweden
well I decide fighting for free speech
and all that good stuff
yeah I actually like it we'll read books
I will be on the Internet
I will go out with friends normal
eighteen-year-old stuff yeah when you
see people or maybe you don't see it but
in America we have this sort of strange
view of Sweden right now because it's
become sort of a hotbed of this where
people are saying oh they're afraid to
say what they think I get a lot of email
from Sweden from people saying that the
political correctness has gone kind of
crazy do you feel like it's going to be
okay that that people like you and your
voices are getting heard enough I'm
really seeking an awakening here in
Sweden more and more people
are really starting to understand that
there is something wrong happening and
if we saw during the beginning of the
refugee crisis the elites that media
then we see mainstream media and the
politicians all said well it's all fine
and dandy there's no problem and then we
saw alternative minute media sites and
populist parties starting to speak out
about this and they became more and more
popular today you'll see if someone
speaks up about it and the media will
still call them racist and the
politicians will still turn against them
but the in general people will stand
with them yeah so what do you think is
the best way for all of these countries
not just Sweden but for countries that
take in families like yours and it
sounds like you had a little bit of a
unique experience in a very positive way
because your parents were so focused on
education and work and all that what
would you say to the societies what's
the best way to integrate these people
for people that do want these societies
to function properly and and have great
young people like you like what do you
think is the best way we need to
integrate them by showing them what our
about values are there's this idea that
all cultures are equal and I really
don't agree with that and yeah if you
have a culture that oppresses women it's
it's lesser than that Western values we
have here and we need to spread them one
thing that is important is that we don't
force them to not say what they want
they should be able to hold any ideas
they want but in school which should
really try to spread there our values
and because you'll see immigrants at
home being pushed more towards their
values than in school and so I think yes
that is one thing the other thing is
that not to have as much segregation as
you have today try to and make it so
that a immigrants show
though in the same school as Swiss yes
for example the school I went to was
like 95% immigrant and the only sweets
we saw there were the teachers do you
have any family that still in Syria now
and yes there are still a few people
with they I think they are living in
camps and some of them are in Jordan and
actually some of my family were able to
compare and them really thankful for
that Wow and that's what the real
immigrant experience is because I'm sure
you're now able to share with them all
the things that you love about living in
Sweden exactly and I find it really I
really think that the countries that are
like Sweden should help countries that
are having a hard time now that's what
we did during 2015
it was unplanned and what we saw is the
people that came where I actually
economic my words not refugees and we we
didn't talk honestly about it and I
think the poor idea of trying to help
other people here or there is very
important yeah well I think you're just
such a wonderful example of how this is
supposed to be you you came at a very
young age from another place you've
embraced your culture you're obviously
incredibly incredibly bright I think you
maybe you could host this show for me
sometime if I go on vacation what do you
think it will sit yeah let you know how
much we pay off camera low let you know
all right I am on with Akira in Cambodia
and for certain security purposes we're
going to do this one just with audio you
were in a small number of people about
ten people or so that had requested to
come on and didn't want to show their
face obviously we're sensitive to that
and that's how we're going to do it so
that's my little preamble Akira thanks
for doing this and how are you I'm doing
all right how about you I'm good I'm
good so tell me a little bit about your
situation now obviously there are
certain security concerns we don't have
to get too much into why
you would not want your face shown but
just tell me a little bit about yourself
to start let's let's do that first
well it's a it's a bit confusing to try
and explain exactly who I am because but
essentially I I have a British mother a
half British mother and she's but she's
Japanese
and I've also out but I was born in the
US and so that's so forgive the accent
and I guess you could say another reason
I'm in Cambodia is because I have a
Cambodian wife and so and met her in the
US and then came over and Cambodia with
her and um but regarding my situation
the reason I'm not showing my face is a
lot of over here I mean over in the
States
I actually used to live in Los Angeles
so I'm very familiar with that area all
right um I'm over here in the in
Cambodia there's two kinds of free
speech that you don't have essentially
you have I mean over in America you can
can criticize the government all you
want now some people would say well no
you can't do that but then but you
actually can and you don't to worry
about any repercussions just fairly
recently over here about a minute from
where I live political I guess you could
say critic um which is shot dead right
in the middle of a gas station he just
went to get feel and he was gunned down
in the middle of wherever he was and
then he's now is gone and so that one
recently but then unfortunately I don't
actually criticize the government that
often but the kind of free speech that
and the second kind of free speech that
we don't really have over here is the
kind of free speech that that I really
see is just completely disappearing in
that states I mean I've lived in this
state for almost ten years now but when
I see these beautiful such as these anti
fascist you know coming around a
recently the Berkeley riots and it is I
mean somebody down because they don't
like what they're saying that's what's
happened to me in the past is that if
you want real racism or real something
that people don't agree with you and
we've had our business literally burned
down to the ground and there's no such
thing as insurance it'll compensate you
so for when it's burned down it's gone
when you're when it's looted and then
when you have people literally showing
up to your gates threatening you set
thing you're here not us you're not one
of us we're going to kill you I'm going
to take everything away from you then it
really puts it into perspective of what
kind of when you actually you can say Oh
somebody said something mean on Twitter
something mean on Facebook but it's not
the same thing as somebody coming to
your doorstep with weapons saying we're
going to kill you because you're not us
or we're going out like what you say
because and so that's the second kind of
free speech and this is why I wanted to
actually come on and speak out is
because I said to myself well if I don't
stand up and you have people that are
afraid to that are always afraid to
stand up then the thugs win and when
they win then the country degrades are
meeting people for the record Cambodia
is not in Africa I know it sounds like
Somalia or something right but a lot of
people but it's in Southeast Asia it's
right next to Vietnam but I'm in one of
the poorest countries in the world
that's not at war right now it's minimum
wage as five US dollars a day and but
yet still gas is still at 350 a gallon
and so if you look at it and you what
you could say well is it that because
the people are not working part or is it
because the government's keeping us down
and I say look I'm a business owner
I want to start a business here I want
to provide better services here but I
can't because if I invest more money I
risk it all being taken away because
people don't like what I say or they
don't like the way I look yeah all right
so all right so let's let's pause there
so you've given a lot they're not only
explaining obviously the situation in
Cambodia but also that you see the
beginnings of this happening in America
where you used to live
so what piece of you I understand you
said you married a woman from Cambodia
but I suspect there must be a piece of
you that would say we've got to get out
of here I need to be able to express
myself properly and and perhaps more
importantly owned a business and not
have all of those other risks and things
yeah a lot of me says I really do want
I'm one of those people where I don't
know if it's evolutionarily speaking it
doesn't make much sense
I like to stand up for what's right but
I don't like to remain silent on issues
where I I feel there's something wrong
here you know and so a lot of me does
want to go and to have I guess you could
say to really be in a place that there
is free speech I do like to I guess you
could say that I would like to move to a
different country but at the same time
some of me feels like it's what's better
should I just go to different country
start off my own business and do
something for myself and try and speak
out there or where would I make more of
a difference and I also have my family
over here and if they don't understand
what free speech is if they don't
understand you know what you know how
great I know people sometimes they say
America is not great you know you go to
wars with not all sorts of different
countries and and I say that it's it's
not the point if you look at a society
in America I mean I can tell you hands
down it it's fantastic like there used
to live in Los Angeles and Los Angeles
has its problems I know but know be
there the traffic can be quite difficult
it's nothing compared to here you should
have just recently I have a commute of
seven kilometers from where I live and
it takes me about two hours to get to
where I'm going to be and oh my god so
it's about four miles and you know I
have a little episode compact car and it
gets ten miles to the gallon because I
can't go faster than two miles an hour
and so foul so without for people that
know nothing about Cambodia because it's
obviously not a place that we're very
focused on generally here in the States
what kind of government actually does
Cambodia have and and how much impact
the people have on the people that are
ruling them um truth be told I mean a
well I mean it's hard to summarize this
when it there's um but I'll try and
summarize it the best that I can from my
perspective the government has been
labeled largely as a - a totalitarian
but it's strong alarm so if there are
protests going on the military police
not just your regular no police men
with the spinning lights on the car
coming I mean the actual militaries with
ak-47 some they'll show up and they will
and they will use force to to quiet the
people down now they don't just gun them
down
I mean I know Cambodia's the probably
the only thing people know about here is
the genocides that happened in the hands
of the Khmer Rouge and but it's it's not
like that anymore it's not totality and
you're not going to be shot for just
saying something that you don't know
that the government in general doesn't
like I know I just mentioned the
political dissident who has gone down
but again it's an iffy situation there's
a ton of corruption over here at the
same time and you can't really say that
was from the dictator himself or the
however you want to it's called the
Prime Minister but people call him
dictator it's very complicated just like
hell it's complicated in the US but it's
strong on but it's relatively free for
example if I want to I wanted to start
my business I could and so I did with my
but it was essentially it was the people
that was what made it very difficult for
me to keep things going because we're
not Cambodians by race and no that's
what I tried to hit on when I said we
don't want two types of free speech over
here is because one yes legally we are
allowed to do certain things but at the
same time by because of the people
because of a certain and to be clear not
all Cambodians are this way I mean if
we're proportion a good proportion of
wonderful people and but it's the but
there's that certain size of mob and
then once they form you it makes things
almost impossible to do just like how
you know if you want to open up a coffee
shop let's say in the Berkeley area and
you wanted to I don't know have some
different opinions in the norm I mean
how long is it until some you know
someone that's going to go bash your
windows in so well in Berkeley it could
happen within about five minutes but I
see your point
even though even beyond that all right
so we have to wrap up here but I thought
a fitting last question in a situation
like this would be how important and an
integral to your life is the Internet in
a situation like this where it
as a human you can't fully express
everything how important is your ability
to connect with other people do things
like this and and chat about free speech
or video chat with people or whatever
else when when in your day to day life
it's obviously a little more tenuous you
know for me the Internet is absolutely
essential and when I had written into
your staff I it said I want to dig fine
restore hope with mobile LED duration
obviously we can't get every point but
and but it does tie into that because so
many people of my generation and
celebrate my birthday like yesterday and
until 29 so not that all happy birthday
though but of so many people of my
generation okay thank you
so many people in my generation they
lose hope I mean there's statistics
everywhere where people are saying oh I
have no future what am I going to do I'm
no no I can't be a superstar I can't be
a sports star I can't do whatever it is
they think they can't do and I say to
them look I'm over here in a country
where if you work eight hours a day
your wages sixty-three cents an hour I'm
in a country where I live next to an
open sewer and yet I'm here talking to
you back in LA and over in the internet
and I have all the potential in the
world to do anything I want and so does
my family because all the information
exists out there the ability to talk to
other people like mine's know it exists
I mean essentially all of the potential
in the world exists right front of you
but when you don't understand that it's
there it's hard to have hope and like I
say an answer to your question the
Internet is absolutely essential for
people and I think for restoring hope in
this generation because it's that road
that nobody knows is there and it's that
road that we need to start walking as
Millennials that because we've been
taught we need to be a certain way we
don't have to be a certain way we can't
there's so many opportunities now like I
said I'm in one of the poorest countries
in the world and I'm talking to you
if that's not amazing I don't know what
is and I genuinely mean that well you've
given me a little hope in that people
are trying to find some answers and
connect all over the place and I think
we
amplify this to get out to a lot of the
type of people that you'd love to hear
it so I thank you and I and I wish you
the best of luck out there all right I'm
on with two boar in Hungary - boar how
are you thank you very much thank you
letting me on the show I'm fine oh you
I'm good so of all the 20 people that
I'm going to talk to you I actually know
you the best because you're one of the
winners of our patreon golden ticket and
you're at the hundred dollar level so
that means that for the last six months
or so or eight months maybe even longer
you've been part of the group chats the
small group chats that I do with ten
people and I've gotten to know you
pretty well and I always say in the
group chat you're one of the one of the
people that actually make it really good
because you're you're in a different
part of Europe you have very specific
thoughts on things you hate the
regressives
and all that stuff so I've TD up tell me
a little bit about yourself well I am
almost fully I born in the Communist era
and I live like eleven years of my
childhood in the Communist era and I
have difficulties we are loving being
the regressive left and all that sounds
of spells Marxist right that's way I'm
correct the project manager this is the
joint immense Hunger Rica and I'm trying
to find a way to to understand better
what's happening and how can I help the
things happening here in Hungary and
possibly even a sort of it what actually
was it like growing up under communism
well eleven years and it was the like
chimerism like if I can say that it was
called the goulash communism you can eat
but nothing else I think much more not
too much plan to use not too much things
to enjoy for example if we had if we had
a cartoon from American from the Western
Europe it was curium it was really a
good thing to have right and and just by
stepping into the era when the Soviet
Union was falling apart and the hungry
has become independent that is a really
eye-opening experience from my childhood
as well because suddenly Christianity
was not that simple
suddenly we could do whatever we want
but I have to admit that the capital
side when I was a child when I was the
school it looks like that my teachers
did not even believe that we can speak
now we can do whatever we want because I
was how can I say it in English I did
not prepare for the work you know the
redneck like a young Patriot I think
this is two years after the Soviet
Union's collapse right so what that's
fascinating to me that you're in a
communist Society and I gather you were
still young eleven but that even after
things changed that chill factor of not
even being able to realize that you can
talk and speak up and talk about ideas
and read certain books and all that
stuff
how long do the remnants of that still
exist today like for an older generation
maybe there's very old generation maybe
that is a layered in society who wishes
it back for some reason because the like
like capitalism that we enjoy now
requires you a lot implies a lot of
efforts to put into your future for
example in socialist country you get
everything from the government you your
job is secured if you're not doing any
job you are you take it to jail for
example mmm-hmm it has a special name
for that like KMP it's a very dangerous
work avoider right so now you have to
work now we have to be an interpreter
editor you have to take to make money my
generation I think my generation is the
best in Hungary so far not because I'm
part of it you realize that we have to
do things to to get better for example I
started the literary of nothing
including with my wife and we are living
a very good life now mm-hmm two kids
third isn't coming so everything is
great but the regressive left started to
take on our youth the universities not
they are not so bad shaped like in the U
in the US but it's getting there it can
really bad yeah so what are you doing or
what are people in the public that do
get this what are they doing to push
back on that kind of stuff
well well I know what you're doing
because you're doing this with me right
now yes and other things but we don't
have time to discuss it doctor we have
activists on the regressive side and we
have very passive anti regressive if I
can say that the record services are
very loud very very annoying they have
lots of money tons of money they have to
spend for example the three biggest
major media outlets selling in their
hands so everything happens that that's
outrageous you will have publicity you
can then you then you imagine I don't
know if you are familiar with the CU
scandal here now I'm not after you okay
University scandal I'm surprised because
the regressive media sells that
everybody is outraged even American
outrages are the scandal I don't I don't
think I know what it is what is it
Central European University is the
source
founded University in Hungary it's an
independent outside University which
teaches certain certain classes certain
degrees they are selling and the
government is just as opposed to that
very right buddy harsher their sell and
what like like social justice 101 kind
of thing oh I can tell you their entire
platform let me tell you the three most
the three most useful in our Hungarian
economy might be the history philosophy
and academic analysts these kind of
useful but listen to this Women's and
Gender Studies minority politics
political science public policy
environmentalist and management they
used to stuff that you are you you are
reduced right right
what it takes so they're just outraged
that we try to close this university and
even even Georgia has you know had a
[Music]
protest against it they even try to
frame a Berlin's progress and set it up
like it once again see see you but it
was it was just a throwing you
protests some guys who didn't Berlin
just stand there with some sign for the
pro see you propaganda and they took the
photos and they promoted that thousands
in billions will protest it again to see
you know huh well if you're media if
you're media over there is telling you
that we're hearing about this it somehow
has gotten over my head but but maybe
somebody knows about it so I know you
know your politics kind of inside out
but a couple of the things that you
wanted to talk to me about first off you
wanted to talk a little bit about
atheism I've gotten to know you pretty
well I didn't know you were an atheist I
I'm obviously fine with that but what is
it that you wanted to say about atheism
Allah hi I'm an atheist but I think a
natural-born eight is from my very early
youth not because of communism just did
not resonated with me the Catholic
teachings did not affected me the Bible
was too sedative like and I never could
grab on that but although when I started
to dig digging deeper what comes with
these problems today in a society and
the wider why Europe is falling so fast
into the pit mm-hmm I have to dig into
deeper and every time I found the answer
that if the main reason is the abandoned
of the religion and I wanted to
understand it more better a bit deeper
why they are saying that because
something that actually not nothing not
necessary for me for existence I wanted
to know why that so big deal yeah and I
don't want to rob the to money time of
you but after my digging and even fish
but I just finished with the New
Testament and with Christianity and with
some prominent skeptic secular people
that I think it is a huge mistake
abandoning Christianity and atheism
today does lots of damage it's a pretty
fascinating point so I want people to
really understand that you're saying
that you as an atheist as a non-believer
did some research and you saw that the
abandonment of some of the religious
values has actually been a net bad for
society I've had a couple people on my
show I think somebody like Dennis Prager
has mentioned that that concept that the
further we get away from these ideas
that it's bad for society now I'm a
secular center not
we were a non-believer myself but I
think it's a fascinating concept and I
like to explain I mean a lot of the
process person but he always provides a
religious answer for this question I
started to find a secular answer for
this I tried to find something that I
can present to my atheist friends or the
Atheist community to grab on and I found
the most the most appealing point is the
communication problem because atheists
are using secular philosophical
reasoning which which is which requires
one hundred and five hundred and ten IQ
average and you know that by this by
using this you just exclude 60% of the
population just by talking region and I
tried to use abstract effect thought oh
god that's pretty depressing very vague
yes but we can but I think we can build
a bridge for example I think atheists
can consume the Bible if we do some
things like the image of God and the
cost of the pastor life we can just
replace that and the focus on the
Christianity is main focus which is
individualism and the betterment of self
nothing at everything it works and it
fails and that's it I'm with you brother
all right so final thought we learned
about a minute left you had mentioned
that you also want to talk about just
generally IQ and how that relates to
society and you mentioned you're also in
Mensa although I think you said you're
leaving why are you leaving Mendte
I'm leaving medicine because I did not
solve when I came for I saw the title
talking people about the what is like
you exactly because it's not integers
it's a property just like mussels height
or anything anything at a property of
the human can can have but it's not
intelligence I thought like one or two
prominent men from the Menza anger
ikkaku who agree with me that the IQ is
just the just the thought possessing and
the short term memory a lots of other a
lot of other attributes contributed
intelligence
for for human being and the most
important nobody speaks about it's a
thought processing method how do you
think how do you file knowledge IQ is
just a very good very good attribute to
achieve that but it's not everything you
need you need the medium term memory
long term memory and the most
importantly is the operating system of
your brain which is which is quite
corrupted if you use an ideology far
less well I feel like that's a perfect
way to end this with you and I've
enjoyed getting to know you when we're
doing our group chats and and it's
always nice to talk to me that's clear
and they're thinking it has a certain
set of beliefs so I'm glad that
everybody else is going to get to know
you as well all right I'm with Michael
in New Zealand Michael how's it going
very a nice day they did good good so
New Zealand whenever I see New Zealand
what pops into my head is lamb lamb
chops rack a lamb lamb leg lamb shoulder
is there a lamb shoulder I'm not sure
what's going on with the lamb in New
Zealand well they tell me it's pretty
good so to be honest I have to make
sport or really good stuff to you guys
and they kind of get the leftovers but
there's still up to that oh that would
be very depressing you mean you've got
to come to me to get the good lamb even
though they're raising it and it's
pastured out there yeah family so oh
that's very depressing well Trader Joe's
has taken all your good lamb then
because they're doing something well so
all right there's a whole bunch they
want to talk to you about now by looking
at you you are a white male a privileged
white a privileged white male apparently
you're sick of being called a privileged
white male and I think it gets to a
heart the heart of a lot of what I've
been talking about with different people
a lot of what I do with this show you
have a really interesting childhood what
you came from to where you are now which
is why you don't want to be thought of
as a privileged white male take it away
yeah so well I always mention the UK I
grew up in a very cool areas of the
grateful family I mean the place of well
people next rather the ghetto to where
migrants tend to leave so one of the
ways of five white kids in my class was
actually racial minority as well but my
digital childhood was also
but I was sexually abused for about two
years when I was about ten twelve years
old so that something is sort of left a
mark on me but but hasn't fine me and I
serve Dawn's we were very hard to become
quite a successful person and so
obviously I tend to see myself having to
overcome difficulties rather than being
a particularly privileged yeah so it's
that bizarre position where if someone
was just to look at you they would think
one thing and the truth is you you came
from not much financially as you said
came from the projects basically
survived child abuse but you don't look
at yourself as the victim did you have a
moment where you realize that that
ideology that way of looking at life was
not going to fly for you yeah I started
trying to have these conversations with
my first load times because that male
victims not and I realized the love the
ideologies the people practice we're
kind of I'm excluding certain people and
the thing that I realized what the
people tend to use the word victim is it
is the status that it's something to
cling to that defines them rather than
just being something in the past that
happened to you so I prefer to look at
it mm-hmm and what actually brought you
to New Zealand why do you leave the UK
just as a chance of something new less I
was 18 years old wasn't really doing
much in my life and what children is
doing and it's just you know a great
place to have a new start and despite it
the shortcomings the most but it's a
really free place with with pretty much
anyone can accomplish what they want to
people in mind to it yeah so I love that
because you're someone that actually
grabbed ahold of their life and are
doing something good with it there's
there's a couple interesting things here
so you started a Facebook page to talk
about the very issues that you care
about
it's called logic empathy honesty and
you talk about rational dissent and
using logic and reason and all of that
stuff have you had success building
building a community do you have the
frustrations of being a creator and a
curator now mostly it's going really
well so among about 600 followers but
but we can get to be discussions every
now and amazing about my page those that
I don't just try to attract people to
agree with me it's about people coming
to disagree so we can kind of just
discuss any topic so I both share my
biases openly and I let people into my
opinions but I don't try to force
everyone to think the same way and I
think a lot of people really
appreciate that yeah what's the state of
politics and free speech and all that in
New Zealand I mean I think people really
have very little knowledge about New
Zealand I think it goes to lamb and I
read a story about a month ago that you
guys are like selling passports you
could basically get citizenship for like
800 grand or something now it sounds
like maybe it's a little more than that
but I know a lot of rich people are
moving there James Cameron I think just
bought a lot of land there a bunch of
other people what's going on there
politically yes the people subsidy doing
kind of mostly based on that at the
moment there's a lot of foreign
investment happening people buying low
land and houses in particular and so a
big part of the conversation this is a
lecture about what they're calling a
housing crisis which I think a lot of
people worried about is not being able
to have affordable houses people liquor
the whole riders just just can't buy
into the market our average house price
my capital city just the past million
dollars a pretty big deal
but mostly qyz images are pretty
politically apathetic they're quite
passive and don't tend to get involved
and now that we start to see a lot of
them run over from the things in America
about free speech and some of the more
radical extreme less and black
perspectives people are really starting
to wake up to that and have
conversations I think we're really stuck
this a lot more people waiting up here
yeah what's the general thought about
America these days and and trumpism and
our crazy political system do you guys
feel and I know you can only speak for
yourself but as a general concept do you
feel that we're leaking a lot of stuff
all over you yes it's definitely a lot
of that I think in general people do
think that America has a big impact on
Associated Colpitts in the West but it's
definitely a lot of feeling at least one
Wellington which is our capital city
which is a city tend to be very
left-leaning Trump isn't considered to
be a very popular or great candidate for
America and its effects in the world are
not that great but again you do tend to
have a lot of people well not many that
will ever support from both either
myself that do tend to get involved in
the oven to a bad argument to be
presented and try to to be a bit more
than water a voice which which is good
to see ya so let's circle back to
something that we discussed briefly for
a second you want to think that you
wanted to talk about was was rape victim
with the wrong opinions which is sort of
a hard phrase to wrap your brain around
what do you mean by that that comes down
to I guess how today we have started
trying to talk about my experiences and
then have the conversation something
that I discover quite quickly with that
there are certain subsets of people I
think probably quite a small minority
that female rape victims as they are
here a threat to their own existence and
their own narratives which is that
really something perpetrated by men
against women and obviously it is a very
big problem for women but men still tend
to have a chance to talk about it and
one thing I've found is that whenever I
try to get two kinds of attacks on
people one was essentially saying that
by having this conversation you're
undermining the female conversation
therefore you're attacking women over
each other so we look at that one's
completely bananas I can understand
people say it but that I mean that
really makes no sense by talking about
what happened to you it doesn't mean
you're diminishing other people's that
sorry go ahead what's the second one
each idea and so the second one I think
is a little bit more most insidious in
that protest to frame it is that males
can talk about this because there's no
cultural topic topic masculinity which
implies and males and handle the
problems but I've never in my entire
experience been shut down by other men
for trying to talk about problems it's
almost always radical very feminist that
were like they just just share me down
and call me means which I think implied
with the problem is coming from the big
ideologies that are really starting to
be static or most religions
rather than individuals and peoples are
trying to talk about their own
experiences yeah do you think that there
is a counter movement growing to that
when you talk about radical third wave
feminism and obviously I've talked about
this with a whole bunch of people you
know starting really with Christina op
summers but that there's a counter
movement sort of this you know I know
that there's a men's rights movement but
maybe a movement that isn't necessarily
based in logic and reason but actually
just anger like someone like you if you
weren't logical and reasonable you would
end up going to anger here and going to
you know being angry at women and all
that other stuff for silencing you do
you see that like a split there on the
and right side oh yeah absolutely a so
when I started having the conversation
and something I try to do in general is
that I get involved in every such debate
and try to understand everyone here and
so I did spend all the time in the men's
rights activist areas for quite a while
and eventually moved away from that
because there is a lot of that just
anger and hatred and Lt Yoon understand
where that comes from when people are
having their experiences shut it down
and nothing read without conversation
you understand why they get angry but I
think it's important we don't get just
stuck in the same rhetoric that we're
seeking the other side and we're trying
to have an open debate and just put our
created that they only get one come to
their own conclusions yeah what's
interesting about it is that when you
talk about men's rights or any of this
stuff it's it's almost toxic in the way
that we view men like for example I was
speaking at a college last week and a
man came up and asked a question about
men's rights and he did seem a little
angry and anxious and whatever and I
could feel people kind of laughing at
him before he even got the question out
and I tried to be as respectful as
possible because I don't want people to
double down on their anger and all that
but even there in a free speech place
where everyone really is respectful
there's just this this weird feeling
around it yeah I think it comes back to
just people with their own biases and
especially with men's rights is really
easy to imagine management stoic and
passive individuals which might either
capture a large number but it doesn't a
capital answers that are really
vulnerable Society and I might need to
talk about the problems and especially
when you come to talk about men's rights
and encryption people to free speech
rallies and that kind is it there's
always gonna be this perpetual left over
ideology from was prevailing narrative
that feminism essentially that that
females and victims and society men have
pretty much all review classes
yeah well it's pretty clear to me that
you you know your stuff and you're
passionate about it and you're putting
your life's experience into into action
which I of course is great you're also
working on your first book which has a
great title Liberty redefined how
fascism is returning to the West so we
got about a minute left
just give me the idea of the genesis of
what's going on there so basically I
just like to go through
the multifaceted arguments exist on some
language topics that are being
undermined today so rather than trying
to tell a story I just want to address
motion the uncommon so a common beliefs
in society that I think are not being
discussed openly and just give give
another perspective but the perhaps
people haven't considered
nice all right well listen here's the
deal you get that thing published I'll
put you back on the show how about that
that sounds great thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]